[Musica]
ma qual è il vero nome di gerry scotti
secondo bella a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo non vide sono fa vj
nel menu c'e una che fa però siamo su
white day a lei britain school
volevo solo dare un piccolo donne
insieme a il diario che aveva perso sì
certo fammi capire nella regia che si
chiude così un cancello non dovresti
tornare a casa subito prova ragazzi l'ho
pagato 30 euro sto gioco già mi ha
commosso l'inizio quindi sono tutti ben
spesi
ma tu due domande non hai voglia di
parte le immagini telefo edificio
principale senza nevano 13 marzo prima
dovrei andare nell'area comune terzo
anno ciao chiesto rumore è un attimo se
i miti al telefono del 1800 servizio è
momentaneamente assente paga posizione
non può essere confermata però a meno di
30 euro era compresa la traduzione del
gioco non vedo niente troppo buio e che
ora bourne è colpa mia c'era non so poi
la torcia ce l'hai una torcia in su
giocano a c'e la luce che ha posto un
succo latte di soia va bene ho trovati
del latte di soia bene così che i cessi
nel corridoio regala potete tutti scemi
siete buongiorno avrei bisogno qua
vendono i condom e regala brutta storia
mi one o poco iata questa porta
[Applauso]
credo ci sia qualcun altro nella scuola
guarda che notizia che mi dai
dio benedica la corea
grazie gesù ecco perché hanno scelto
quale in piedi ciao zio sto qua io è il
toro vis comica stand anche voi mi avete
spaventato bene quello che guarda i culi
in cortile dove vai che chiuso dovrai
dove a questa stesse ma pensano tutti
kim si chiamano kim sung corea che sta
roba
alcune volte la stessa di song han solo
sì anche a te piace sono gli ambienti
ragazzi punto ci crede ciecamente
va bene keepers of the hill a quanto ti
aiuterò
scusami cosa sai chi saresti tu cosa
dovrei farti scusa con 50 euro al minuto
credo di poter montare su di te eseguiti
sembra l'inizio di un po solo che non è
un po a quanto pare anche dove si stanno
dirigendo sembra l'inizio
però
facetime grosbard
no veramente ci sono stato prima che
guardavo le voglie dimmi solo come vuoi
che ti aiuti una donna lega mai buoni
taiwan santin weir
no per carità ma devo infilarmi nel
condotto di areazione
ma guarda neanche fosse selena gomez zia
prova facciamolo perché se non andiamo
avanti nel gioco anch'io sarà cammino di
prego ma mi da bar scala un attrezzo
tagliente guardano come a un dehor
occhiata zia faccio io io che sono
esperto di cose taglienti e di scale
perché le ho detto di sì che i rapitori
e lei no il potere la patata regala
patata fa fare questo e altro
incredibile un qui e di sottofondo sento
satana da quando abbiamo iniziato a
giocare è normale questo lega eccolo qua
perfetto italiano ma di un semplice
italia file boj usarla per tagliare i
fioretti e fili sottili va bene o ecco
anche la scala perfetto a cianchi così
per prendere le bibite cioè i sordi
faccio il moneygram perfetto e sorpresa
la lattina caffelatte sembrano quelle
latine che vendono in giappone fanno
veramente vomitare quelle delle
macchinette gole così del caffè prove si
sta roba
assortimento di attrezzi per prendere
alla scala per fare una cosa alla volta
era che posso fare pure il segretario
qua pronti qual è il telefono che
squilla non ho capito però se squilla il
telefono spia tre volte un attimo da
mittente via ci siamo ragazza questa è
la scala e faccio io per carità siamo
mai che tu faccia qualcosa
vado è per carità di dio non mi guardare
il deretano si sa mai
va bene cosa non si fa per la patata tu
guarda mi pure se tranquilla
ma chi caso a caso
ma cosa completo
logica perché ma completamente random
sta roba ragazzi meccanico simulator o
gesù a posto bene
[Musica]
ora gas arendt il successo c'è un
cerchio a chimico sono l'archivista di
plastica che devo fare qua che devo fare
acqua dalla mia vita ma ce lo debba
collegarli tutti può far giocato un
sacco al professor layton barra qualcosa
per collegarli tutti devo fare
non ho anche capito cosa ho fatto ma va
bene chiaro che aveva di economia e la
patata è tutta mia
uscire a parte che la luce l'acqua che
pirla
la zia a posto è no picasso mani pippo
tyler già in atto le persone morte tipo
te stesso e mi sono cagato addosso lo
giuro anche siro ma in casa famiglia
tipo avuto un infarto ma attivi e
sacchetti da roma idea che ci open air a
new way out come adesso santi mitico
devi fare qua spiega cosa deve fare
questa va bene fai quello che vuoi sensi
visto come fissa tranquillamente la
finestra non ti preoccupare che capisco
i tuoi impegni
comunque devo andare avanti 9 8 dopo
hanno capito perché questa giusto e
credo ancora troppo l'ho aperta
io vado e non so cosa sto facendo
provato perché se sto ancora in balia di
gola tizia mi suicido
[Musica]
perché ha fischiato spiega mito problemi
cioè ci sono solo io qua
quante che zocco ma chi è poi il bidello
la corri
cori e sfruttata una tizia io non ho
parole regala lo giuro senso questa è
quella di prima come centrata quando ci
aveva la chiave per chi è scossa e
fismic e mai piceno giacché tutti avere
sono accorto sai non so perché voi che
ci siano punishment si ammazza proprio
tommie sunshine boy simone in noi che
faccio youtube ott e migliaia di suoi
io mi coulson è l'assenza in torna come
sempre ancora né con bene mi piaceva la
sagoma della divisa mi sembrava tizio se
il giocatore viene scoperto dal bidello
mentre questi effetto la sua ronda verrà
rincorso ostinatamente no perché non ho
capito è duro
l'hacker randellata forte non pensavo
che accenderà la luce in fricassea dove
avete capito è chiusa la porta io voto 6
rifilato ragazzi ci sono delle cose che
non capisco il soggiorno però va bene
tu sei un mago harry nel caso non
l'avessi capito
posso entrare nella parte è sparito il
bidello bene cosa che cosa ho fatto
questa app central quasi usate avevo
capito cosa non l'ho capita però vabbè
[Applauso]
cosa sta scricchiolando esattamente i
quaderni insam minardo quadernoni
matematica macchiate di sangue in più o
meno il mio quaderno di matematica era
uguale è più o meno c'è una farfalla la
phard alla ha le ali a forma di corpo
umano
secondo me tu sei un porco prova beh
abbiamo un lucchetto qua regate non ho
capito però sicuramente c'è qualcosa di
dentro dobbiamo trovare il codice mi
fate capire dove dovrei arrivare questo
lavoro comune
come rimane qua dentro quel ke
messo
era chiusa a chiave e te pareva figure i
problemi cintura porta attrezzi contiene
cacciavite di varie dimensioni 41 25
sarà mica la password del lucchetto le
prima per forza l'unica roba dove
mettere i numeri anche perché se non è
quello non soffrivo andrà avanti
non avevo notato prima i gatti morti
come possibile passo e 41 25 contro 125
o l'ho aperta chiave passaggio uditori
un edificio principale uno va a 102 di
chiavi addirittura sembra che si possa
combinare con altre chiave è quello
l'audi di questo è l'auditorium sì cioè
non è il passaggio almeno si è aperta
porca vacca e ceppi delle bidelle bl
salve che è successo o meno male
i bidelli schifosi
salve
e vabbè mica è una corda di me
mi sa che hai dei problemi alle
articolazioni però non ne sono proprio
convinto
quindi ragazzi vorrei chiudere qui il
primo episodio di white day non mi
ricordavo il nome fa piacere che
continuamente la corea è molto più
presente nei miei video c'è il che hip
hop questo il che hip hop però che vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi come se sì vi è
piaciuto il momento mi piace anche
affari sociali dove iniziare se dovessi
scrivere ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
visto dai ragazzi
[Musica]
no